well chaka khan has won 10 grammys she's
a singer actor and activist chaka khan
she is a legend shaka along with swv
will be at craig ranch amphitheater this
sunday and earlier i spoke with shaka
and concert promoter precious maize
about the show
[Music]
shaka i'm going to start with you okay
10 grammys you're writing books you're
still putting out music you're still
performing what is the secret to staying
on top for so long
sleep
[Laughter]
really truly
lots of sleep
um if i'm not working
i'm sleeping
[Laughter]
you know i get out you know i you know i
live in a nice area i walk around pushed
my great-granddaughter around the block
several times
and that's pretty much it and i sleep
and watch a lot of television
precious your story i love your story
because you're an entrepreneur woman and
you've kind of mastered the medical
fields and then you you branched out and
you've launched she mogul so tell me why
did you launch it and kind of what's
your goal what's your goal here by
launching it first of all women have a
powerful voice and it's often missed out
there in the industries in any industry
whether it's healthcare or entertainment
or music
and so
being able to put a brand on chemical
media and bring
bringing concerts um that are able to
heal and get back to charity and and
iconic concerts with amazing
uh ten grummy artists like shotgun
do that and bring it to the smaller
cities and the amphitheaters out there
[Music]
we love you know hearing you sing and
watching perform and it's so funny with
your concerts because i told a friend of
mine last night um that i'm gonna be
interviewing you two and he mentioned
he's in the medical field and but he
mentioned that he had he was at a
fundraiser and chaka khan you were
performing at one point you came up and
you sang a lyric to him just one little
lyric and that moment stuck with him
this was maybe 10 years ago that moment
stuck with him so i think people leave
your concerts they're an experience do
you go to concerts and if so have you
ever had that experience as an audience
member you're watching a performer and
you just go wow this is something i'm
never going to forget
well you know i have that experience
every show i do as well
it's really important to me to get as
much eye contact
and some touching which i'm doing less
of these days for some reason you and
prince became very close friends but is
it true that in order for prince to meet
you he um told a little white little lie
when he set up your first meeting and
called you and said it wasn't prince but
he was sly stone in order to set up the
meeting is that true he called me i
except in san francisco he called me on
the phone and he sounded exactly like
slices i'm up here i said you're not yes
i am okay where are you aces i'm in
marin county i said okay i don't even
see you there was one studio with the
lights on so i went in and there's this
guy in there this little short guy with
a guitar by himself
and so i said well what's
really going on so
i asked him where is sly
and then he said
that it was him he said about that was
me
i said
this little thing with this big voice
this big deep voice is guy i thought i
said well he's really good
i think he's gonna really make some
noise and he
really really did and we became great
friends
[Music]
two legends right there
what a great interview jason i really
enjoyed that you need a chair like her i
know i got nothing fancy behind me
shocked shishaka khan i mean she's the
queen of funks she has the best chair in
town sunday craig ranch park is when her
concert is going to take place hopefully
the weather will be great on sunday hey